authorities in North Dakota have cracked
down big league on protesters
challenging the Dakota access pipeline
they've been sort of cracking down for
months but it reached a new level over
the weekend when police actually started
spraying activists activists with water
cannons freezing water and a hundred and
sixty-seven protesters were injured
Sunday night alone tear gas was used
rubber bullets were used concussion
grenades were used and a sound cannon
against protesters at least three
elderly people were among the injured
and there's a bunch of different videos
that have been posted on social media
which show protesters fleeing in terror
as authorities are shooting water at
them and temperatures as low as 25
degrees Fahrenheit the wind chill making
that seem even 10 degrees lower here's
one video and you'll see and hear the
chaos very clearly
nearly everyone in the crowd is coughing
spitting up due to heavy amounts of
teargas defines the crowd and we have
one other video to show you here as well
from the protests over the weekend water
water everywhere
now the sheriff spokespeople have been
caught lying I'm going to play for you
some drone footage as I tell you that
sheriff's spokesman Rob Keller said that
there was no water cannon used and that
all water was sprayed from a fire truck
to control fires and as you can see if
you're watching this footage no fire
truck and no fires that is indeed a
water cannon just being used to hose
down protesters numerous cases of
hypothermia because it is absolutely
freezing at least 17 protesters taken to
the hospital and legal observers from
the National Lawyers Guild said
yesterday that some activists were
actually shot in the head with rubber
bullets what's the big question here
well what would an incoming president
donald trump administration do with
regard to the types of businesses that
would want pipelines well we actually
got a preview because energy transfer
partners is the company that's building
the dakota access pipeline they have
just joyously announced a twenty billion
dollar merger with Sunoco logistics and
this is being called the first Trump
deal by CNBC host Jim Cramer who said
quote pipelines are gonna be winners
under Trump and ETP CEO Kelsey Warren
said he was very very enthusiastic about
what's going to happen with our country
why will things be so good for oil and
gas under Trump well start with his
campaign promises to roll back
regulations on fossil fuel companies uh
and then look at the fact that CEOs
including the CEO what will be the
newly-merged pipeline company gave over
a hundred thousand dollars to Donald
Trump to the campaign and we know Pat
that Trump is a big believer in hey you
play the game and he played the game and
now he's on the opposite end of the game
being played authorities will be more
empowered to use these sorts of tactics
to keep protesters down more things like
rubber bullets oh yeah bring people with
fire hoses it's very troubling yet that
the continued militarization of American
police will will be seen under the
President Donald administration
oligarchy it's happening by the way
Trump is a big shareholder in a lot of
the companies that
make money from oil and gas development
Trump himself in fact a stockholder in
ETP so Trump stands to make money
big-time from a lot of these mergers and
pipelines it's not looking good folks it
is not looking good